[Music]
so if you have any strategies for
mitigating like what if you're thinking
about doing something what do you look
at to sort of separate good risk and bad
risk good risk for me has a few
characteristics my two of the key
characteristics would be hi hi 90 plus
percent likelihood of developing
developing or deepening skills that will
transfer to other things okay whether
now or in the future even if this
project fails another characteristic of
good risk would be developing
relationships that can transcend this
project yeah even if it fails and this
is borrowing from scott adams quite a
bit the creator of Dilbert who talks a
lot about this type of thing
how to win even if a project fails
another characteristic of good stress
would be something that will help me to
develop attributes or emotional
resilience or to take things less
seriously which I think often go
together
yeah to try something that is scary to
me or to most people that I can
demystify in such a way that it's less
intimidating yeah right the podcasting
and doing six episodes is a great
example yeah so in the beginning the
idea of podcasting in my head was having
this big studio and almost equipment and
it's This American Life or the staff 40
people and no it's not after six
episodes like all right actually I'm not
scared sure my audio at all yes these
mics these cables and the recorder
that's on this chair yeah like five
hundred bucks and you're right locked
and loaded and the editing is actually
pretty straightforward so those are
three characters of good risk and then
bad risk I think is largely a function
of allowing unknowns that don't need to
be unknowns and so I do a lot of
homework for many of my bets if I'm
looking at say Austin okay I want to
understand
what the landscape political legal and
so on looks like in Austin I want to
look at population growth I want to look
at employment growth yeah I want to look
at median home costs yeah and how prices
are moving not just in Austin but
compared to my other options on the
table so the opportunity cost of it it's
a relative decision it's not an absolute
decision yeah because and I'm also gonna
look at let's say if I stay in San
Francisco what are what are the risks of
the status quo yeah I think what are the
knowns that I dislike and then what are
the possible changes that I might
dislike so not just looking at the the
potential upside and downside and pros
and cons of the new option but comparing
it to the current option that sounds so
self-evident but it is not common
practice right most people just assume
all right this is my known and I'm gonna
look at the risks and pros and cons of
this a new option I'm always looking at
relative I'm looking at not just
opportunity cost but the sort of
relative attractiveness right and that
can apply to just about anything I mean
it can it can apply to startups
certainly and the in terms of bad risk
III do look at a financial risk I look
at reputational risk I look at legal
liability risk and I do I do I do more
comprehensive risk assessment than I do
opportunity assessment in part because I
want to look for asymmetric sure that's
yeah in the sense that if I know I can
count my downside that there is little
or I can manage or completely eliminate
reputational legal risk by asking for
let's say an indemnity clause and have
a written record of what we agree my
responsibilities will or will not be and
I'm putting in $50,000 yeah in a sense
if I can control my time that is
allocated to this my max downside risk
is 50% right but if I'm investing in
software as-a-service 50000 sorry if
they have thousand dollars if though I'm
investing in a sector and a vertical and
a type of company like
software-as-a-service or whatever that
has comparables which show a hundred X
returns a thousand X returns I'll take
that bet all day long yeah right if the
team and so on sure give it a reasonable
likelihood of success that is a great
asymmetric bet and I think you can do
that outside of investing in startups I
think investing helps to hone the
questions you ask and the types of lens
through which you look at things and how
you might consider arbitrage and so on
but like Austin for me is a very simple
bet where it's easy to cap the downside
you